Bonsoir Michel.
On va faire le tour. J'ai choisi
trois extraits de trois films
parce que je veux que vous me
parliez. On vient de l'entendre
dire : mon petit Canada celle
j'essaie de faire changer les
choses. On commence. 1974,
bingo, un film qui marquait les
gens qui ont vu. C'est sur
espérer des troupes d'octobres.
Et la police corrompue et les
politiciens qui manipulaient ici
et là certains événements. On
regarde un extrait les gens vont
reconnaître certaines personnes.
- Je vous avais promis
- Veux-tu arrêter de gesticuler
puis de t'énerver, toi,
tabarnak! Si t'es si fin
que ça, à quelle place
tu penses que ça va nous mener?
- À faire réengager
tout le monde!
- Toi, tiens-toi prêt.
Il y a d'autres cellules qui
se préparent pour la campagne
électorale. Ça va swinguer,
tout à l'heure, ti-gars!
(tirs)
♪ ♪ ♪
Est-ce que c'est un bon exemple
que ce qu'a voulu faire Jean-
Claude Lord?
- Oui notamment dans les années
70 puisqu'il a fait cinq au
cours de cette décennie. Il
était vraiment un cinéaste
justicier. Il était citoyen. Du
poil à gratter. Elle parle de la
crise d'Octobre mais le manque
très, il y avait des bavures
policières jusqu'à la toute fin
des personnages principaux sont
les victimes de la police. Elle
montrait tout ce qui se passait
et ce qui agaçait. Ce sera là
tout au long de sa carrière. Ça
va revenir, les élèves, le
pouvoir, et connaissent, ce sont
des sujets qui bafouillent à
l'infini.
- Je me souviens encore de la
fin de bingo, quand on voit ce
film, on s'en souvient toute
notre vie. La faim dans les rues
de Westmount, les bons ne sont
pas si bons.
- Ça fait mal.
- Parlez-nous d'amour, c'est le
titre du prochain film. Une
critique vitrée avec du milieu
de la télévision, et c'est
Michel Tremblay qui signe le
scénario. Jacques Boulanger joue
dedans. On écoute un extrait.
- Je vous avais promis
une grosse surprise. Ah, ca,
pour être grosse, elle est
grosse, vous allez voir!
Voici un de vos chanteurs
favoris, qui est mon ami depuis
des années, Pierre Vigneault!
- Bonjour, à demain.
- Pauvre toi, j'espère qu'elle
avait pas la syphilis.
Essaye donc de me vendre
ton public, astheure!
Est-ce qu'on pourrait le
rediffuser aujourd'hui?
- On le fait régulièrement et
c'est une bombe. Déjà dans les
films précédents il avait
assigné la télévision. Un
concours de chanteurs
malhonnêtes avec les
politiciens.
La, c'est une bombe. Parlez-nous
d'amour. S'il fallait quelque
chose pour Boulanger parce que
dans son propre rôle, il animait
une émission de télévision et
les êtres populaires à ce moment
Mélanie mais dans les films et
les missions ou envoyer que les
producteurs derrière ne penser
qu'au profit et traite les
femmes avec un mépris infini.
Les chanteuses étaient au bord
du suicide. Les gens des médias
faisaient du chantage auprès des
gens. Le public était traité.
Il y a des scènes inoubliables.
Cette image du public par
exemple. Défendre un certain âge
et de certains poids qu'on ne
voit nue devant la personne
qu'elles adorent. Sa frappe.
Toutes ces maisons sociétés
conduisaient sur les artistes
que les gens du public avec
cette préoccupation qui a eu
toute sa vie d'accorder une
place égale aux femmes. De
traiter correctement les femmes.
C'était dès son premier
scénario. Dans son premier film
aussi. On va le voir aussi d'en
lancer compte.
- Il a fait plein de films
après, des films à commande. Il
est venu ceci.
- Accueillons l'homme national!
(acclamations de la foule)
- Go, go, go!
(indicatif muscial de l'émission
Lance et Compte)
Michel, ceux qui sont assez
vieux s'en souviennent. Comment
oublier? On entend la musique.
Cela a été un coup de circuit.
- Oui parce que grand succès
public autour de 2 millions de
spectateurs. Cela a révolutionné
la télé. On a amené le hockey à
la télévision. Tout est à
nouveau et différent. En secouer
les habitudes. On faisait autre
chose que les téléromans. Ce
sera cela toute sa carrière
télévisuelle. La suite, c'est
Jasmine et on est dans la
diversité culturelle. Il y a
divers, et autres. C'est vous
dire à quel point cet homme a
été marquant il était présent au
début des années 60 elle sera
jusqu'à la fin de la décennie
qui vient de se terminer.
Presque 60 ans de présence. Un
travail qui peut ressembler au
mien. Il avait un franc-parler
qui va caractériser la personne
qui est. C'est un citoyen qui
avait quelque chose à dire.
- Il y a des critiques de
cinéma, effectivement elle
disait ce qu'elle pensait. Merci
beaucoup